you couldn't make an ibm uh compatible
computer without ms-dos right so
you know you you definitely uh you know
uh
went to microsoft you know and
and uh you know so i spent a lot of time
with with bill in in the early days
uh you know licensing dos and and and
then through all the adventures of
windows and and and beyond but that that
you know kind of started around
85
when when you know when we started
making making our own our own machines
and
uh our you know our own pcs
what was he like at that time
you know bill
peak bill gates you know in microsoft
taking over the world mode
he was aggressive and you know geeky and
and uh you know uh definitely
uh
you know wanted what he wanted you know
yeah
but but but but also
also
uh
you know
we built we built a strong partnership
and
it was it was
yeah for the most part a win-win how was
it negotiating with him like he was a
front-line negotiator i understand and
pretty aggressive about
this is what you're going to pay for the
operating system and you're not going to
work on anybody else's operating system
and just
his way or the highway is true
i wouldn't quite say it was that extreme
and we actually had other os's i mean we
licensed unix from at t
and tried to develop our own version of
unix in the late 80s that didn't really
work out um
but uh yeah he he he was aggressive but
you know the the stories probably
exaggerate some of that stuff yeah and
so jobs gets kicked out of uh apple
and he decides to create next and then
he starts pitching you on hey maybe dell
should make workstations and the
workstation business you don't do that
but then he gets back inside of app
because there's no apps for next i mean
you could buy a next operating system
but there was literally nothing you
could do with it right like you use the
calculator there's no apps
you know if you go online you search
next operating system next os and dell
you'll find some remnants of things that
were done you know
it never really amounted to much
but you know as you know that next os
became
mac os yeah and so you know steve had
this idea of
licensing the mac os to us which we were
pretty interested in
uh but you know he didn't want us to pay
for every copy of mac os that we used he
wanted us to pay for every pc we shipped
and just ship it on every pc because he
was afraid that
you know we would wipe out his hardware
business
and uh ultimately it wasn't wasn't it
wasn't a deal that that made sense and
and uh you know didn't happen see i
think this is like a seminal moment in
the history of both companies that i
wasn't aware of but if you think about
that moment in time
um
dells were booming people are buying
them like crazy he wants you to put
windows and mac os
almost like a dual boot situation on
everyday the way and the customer would
work
that's right the way it would work is
the machine would would turn on and it
would say you know press one for windows
and two for mac os or something like
that and
then it would
it would
load the operating system we
we we knew how to do it technically it
was it wasn't a big technical problem
but if you think about that moment in
time
apple just could not get market share
from windows windows was crushing it
they were moving much faster they
allowed
any number you could anybody could make
hardware for their
their share their share of pc's peaked
you know uh
before ibm introduced the pc right
so
just going through the scenario the what
if
if steve said you know what just give me
a dollar for every time they you every
pc you ship instead of probably he asked
for 50 bucks for 100 bucks
oh you mean if he'd ask for a dollar for
for every unit yeah because what did he
ask for 50 bucks or something a hundred
bucks it it and it ended up being a kind
of an obscene amount of money because
hundreds of millions a year because of
the number of machines that we were
shipping right you know by that point we
were
we were shipping
you know tens of millions of machines
per year
so
but imagine the scenario when he said
you know what i just want to beat
microsoft i want there to be more mac os
machines than
windows machines i'll give it to you for
100 million dollars flat license fee you
take the deal or 50 million or whatever
he gives it to you for how would the
industry have shaped up after that
yeah i i i it's a great question and you
know one of the other open questions
then was
okay
you're offering us this deal which isn't
very good right now right
what happens in three or four years and
he wouldn't he wouldn't commit to
continually offering it to us you know
in five years or ten years which
i didn't like that at all because
you know it could have been a situation
where we
we created a whole bunch of new users
and and then
you know we we couldn't create a
follow-on product which wouldn't be a
good good strategy for us
take us through the laptop era because
that you know was something i i was in
i.t at that time in the early 90s and
luggables came out and there were
dal had one and compact and hp were all
coming out with these you know seven
eight pound laptops and i think gates
was on this very early apple had one
eventually
um
but
it seemed like they really sucked and
people were down on the market but you
stuck with it explain that decision
making and what it was like because
these things didn't even have batteries
at the time i believe they were just
plug-in luggables that were what eight
pounds nine pounds
well no they were much more and compact
actually started you know with the
original luggable and the thing was
basically like a huge
you know briefcase i think it weighed
you know 15 or 20 pounds and it was it
was basically a
transportable computer desktop computer
you had to plug it in
but then
you know as
as you started to have
better battery technology
first nickel metal hydride and then
lithium-ion as you started to have
the transition from you know crts to
lcds
the miniaturization
you know
it was clear that you were going to be
able to have portable computers and the
other thing that needed to happen was
the semiconductors needed to
use less power because they were
designed for a you know continuous
active current
and that was just you know way too much
power and they wouldn't have long
battery life so
you know we ever everybody in the
industry was focused on how do you
how do you make
you know a machine that's the size of an
eight and a half by 11 sheet of paper
right that's not
super thick and you can go find videos
of
me proudly displaying you know these
machines which are kind of laughable by
today's standards you know today it's
like you got super thin laptops and
yeah incredibly powerful
but back then you know the the idea of
being able to take your computer with
you
was just amazing you know yeah we had
we had uh modems there was no there was
no wireless technology
but all that was part of the the origins
of of you know what what we all enjoy
today
listen right now linkedin is going to
give you a hundred dollar credit towards
your first ad campaign i want you to go
to linkedin.com
this week in startups and get that
hyundy right now now why would you use
linkedin marketing high quality leads we
all need leads we're all running
businesses here my leads startup
founders your leads might be sas
enterprise it might be cfos it might be
cmos it might be ctos who knows
everybody's got a different product but
everybody is on linkedin we all know
that because we all use linkedin every
single day so if you're planning a
launch a new campaign you know your
audience your team is excited and
everything is going according to plan
we've all been there except you have
that one thought in the back your head
how can i be sure that my acquisition
campaign will drive high impact leads
for my sales team well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your message
reaches people who are ready to engage
you linkedin equals business business
equals linkedin you know this it's very
simple so with 30 million companies
engaging and over 71 of professionals
using linkedin to inform their business
decisions
linkedin can help bring your growth to
the next level don't wait to start
achieving your brand and lead gen goals
get a 100 ad credit towards your first
linkedin campaign at linkedin.com
this week in startups once again
linkedin.com slash this week in startups
for the hyundai no spaces no dashes and
terms and conditions applied because
they're giving you a hundy